hi I'm Scott Dunn and I'm Jenna Dunn and
you know I was thinking about something
today
um the kitchen looking at salt it made
me think about today's video I just
thought about the first person who's the
first person who's like this I should
sprinkle this on my food you know it was
probably I thought to myself it's
probably a caveman right a caveman which
means this is this is gonna taste good
on my meat and then I thought there was
probably another caveman who came up to
him and it was uh which is you can't do
that that's a rock looking thing you
can't put that on your food and imagine
if the first caveman listened to that
negative caveman we wouldn't have salt
all right
it wouldn't have salt these things taste
better with salt
how are you fast-forward to today and
2018 in Hollywood and there's cavemen
all over Hollywood who keep telling you
you can't do that you can't do this you
can't do that and a Saracen and we want
to talk to you today about our our
second feature film and a low of the
Dead and all the things people say you
can't do and we did them anyway and if
we hadn't we wouldn't you know be
sitting here with a second feature film
so let's start
can't make a movie or especially a genre
movie for anything less than a hundred
thousand or they won't take you
seriously
well our production budget for Amanda of
the Dead was just shy of thirteen
thousand that's it I round it up you
know it's one of those things where you
have to work with what you got
and tailor your script to fit your
budget and tailor your script to things
that you have available resources that
you have available to you so like our
co-producers chesil Melman and Ian
Sumner graciously lent us their
apartment so we saved a lot of money on
the location say half the movie was shot
there so right there you know saving a
lot of money when I was writing the
script for Mandel I made sure that you
know we we stayed within the confines of
I I knew how about how much money we had
to spend on this feature film right and
I thought well I can write it in very
few locations but it doesn't but we
didn't sacrifice any fun I think it was
about as fun it was as it was ever gonna
be and I actually think that the
limitations made it a better movie and
even our crew our our sound mixer had
all his own equipment our DP had it's
all his own equipment and our associate
producer Oscar Munoz he lent us his
camera gear so it was like just see
finding different ways to save money
without sacrificing quality
number two can't be done in nine days
not a feature film yeah and they were
right it was done in ten days so in that
tenth day was really just a pick-up day
a pick-up day with a couple of
additional scenes after editing and I
saw that there needed to be a few things
to fill in and ten days is still crazy
but again caveman you bad caveman you
said we couldn't do it no no we we were
actually the reason why we were able to
do that is we kept our crew cast and
crew really small so we were able to
move fast and we also rehearsed prior to
shooting we've rehearse with an actor
this is something that I'm very gung-ho
about always get the rehearsals going
before you movie that's where you know
that's where you get to work on it cuz
when you're shooting you don't have time
to explore as much you should know what
you're doing and you know you there's
plenty of room for improvisation on set
I'm just saying do a lot of that work in
the rehearsals the third one this is a
personal experience I I had been in
contact with a producer in Hollywood and
we were talking and we had this sort of
disagreement and he said to me you're
not a writer you're not a director I
mean you're barely an actor and I
remember hearing that it was you know
obviously it's painful you'd painful to
be told that you you're not something I
had just done in the feature film our
first feature film schlep and it hadn't
gotten into any festivals yet he's like
what festivals was it has it gotten into
yeah that's right nothing yet
and I and weirdly enough a week later we
got accepted to our first glance Film
Festival and we had a great showing and
yeah the audience loved it and it was
just a nice thing where you know I'm
glad we didn't listen to people saying
no you mean no one knows anything no one
can tell you that you can't do anything
I mean they can say it but don't don't
believe it for a second it's it can be
really good I will say after all the
time I've been in Hollywood it's been
you know like 10 years and I will say
this it's about how you receive words
like that if you people say you can't do
it you have really two options believe
them or show them and I think it was
actually I'd like to thank that guy
because it pushed me to really prove him
wrong the fourth thing this is an
interesting one I edit my features we've
done - I've edited both okay so so just
to recap he Scott wrote directed starred
and now edited man Day of the Dead
Angela and I like doing it but also it
saves money you know you obviously you
know how what our budget is it helps
save money but I also enjoy doing it I
think that who could know the movie
better than me at this point but a lot
of people were you know when I was
asking on slep like what should I do is
my slap was my first movie so I was like
oh should I edit I get someone else and
a lot of people like you shouldn't edit
your own you know you'll be too close to
it and no it's just not how it's done
and I remember thinking yeah but I want
to I feel like doing it
it's not like I ever felt burdened by it
and it's like who knows the movie better
than you right exactly and so going into
this mandel feature I I felt galvanized
incompetent in editing it and and I
think this is something I'll be carrying
forward to future features because it's
just fine and and you know editing
really it's direct writing is one thing
directing is another thing
editing is another thing like if you can
do all that that as a director the more
I think you'll be more enriched as an
artist it's also staying true to your
own voice like how did you envision this
movie well if you're the writer director
and editor you know you get the last say
in everything so it really the film
really became Scott's voice and also
they said don't do don't use Final Cut
Pro I mean everyone's using Adobe and I
again or avid and and that's true a lot
of people are using that and and there's
no problem with that and the only
problem is when people say you don't use
Final Cut Pro I'm like hi yeah if you
can tell me why great if not then that
kind of information that it's just so
because I don't do it but we did it
anyway and it turned out great
number five oh yeah you can't make money
self distributing your film or in other
words you need a distributor to make
money making your film that's just not
true so for the majority people if
you're really indie you're making your
first feature it behooves you to self
distribute because each platform like
iTunes Amazon etc they take a percentage
of all the sales that you make then the
distributor takes another 30 percent 20
30 whatever yeah after that it's like
then you start seeing some money and by
that point it's like that's a long time
that's a lot of percentages to be taking
out before you see any money and and and
in this case of man Day of the Dead and
schlep we are putting our own money into
it we're putting our time sweat equity
all these things into it and it's like
why give that percentage away especially
in a day and age where you can
distribute yourself yeah you may I think
we're trying to out Blum House the Blum
House model they they make movies for
very cheap right and then they make
between like they make a ton back I mean
the margins on their profits are I mean
they're it's amazing so we're doing that
but crunching it down even further we're
talking like $13,000 that's insane but
it also means that you have more of a
chance of making your money back and
going into black you know I'm making a
profit with your money and that's me
that's attractive to me so I would
suggest let's not let's not let people
tell us no when they don't even they
haven't even tried it try it you'll see
for yourself
number six film school now it's not like
people said you can't do this you didn't
go to film school but it's not like we
didn't feel that I mean I'm survival
like oh you guys didn't go to film
school so like yeah I'm just gonna make
a movie I'm not gonna say sit here and
say don't go to film school cause if you
went there that's great you're gonna
learn so much and it's it's probably
really good to go to film school however
don't let that stop you if you haven't
been there be smart
surround yourself with people who who
know what they're doing who brings
something to your movie don't don't be
so in your own head about you know I'm
the director only I have I had the last
say of course you have the last say but
everyone on your set is it if you got
the right people they're artists they
have good ideas they're smart you
they're not trying to screw with your
they're trying to help you bring your
vision get a good team together so that
you can make the best product that's
that I give credit to everyone on our
movie yeah I mean the vast majority of
our crew went to film school so they
have that technical knowledge and stuff
thank goodness teachers which is great
we needed it but they it was fun to
collaborate with them so yeah so if you
haven't been in a film school so yeah
you know if you have a passion you have
an idea if you have something you can't
get rid of from your head go make it
surround yourself with smart people yeah
I will say that there's just no excuse
you can make your own movie you can
shoot it on an iPhone you can get really
really micro budget India and make a
really good movie it just all depends on
what resources you have available to you
what kind of people will kind of
do you have it comes back to there's a
lot of cavemen in Hollywood mm-hmm don't
let those negative cavemen tell you no
okay otherwise well we wouldn't have
salt right if we listen to all the times
people said you can't do that this world
would be one boring place to live all
you filmmakers out there who who are
waiting for permission I would ask you
just don't wait okay bad caveman bad
listen to the caveman who made the salt
you